this is a little clip from my youtube
channel 2008 i met jeffrey bezos yeah
jeffrey of amazon.com have you heard of
it
well i had the opportunity to ask
jeffrey anything in the world and this
is what i decided was important what is
your favorite treat my favorite treat
yeah um well let's see you mean like
food
probably bread pudding i've really never
met a bread pudding that i don't love
like 2008 justine was like yo jeffrey
what's up dude wanna know what your
favorite treat is i'd love to know red
pudding that's your favorite treat he's
never met a bread pudding that he hasn't
liked
i wonder if that still stands true here
in 2022 jeffrey bezos do you still like
bread pudding have you met one over the
past what is the math on that
13 years jeffrey curious if over the
past what 13 years if you've met a bread
pudding you haven't liked we really we
need an update we need to know the
people
need to know i need to know